my MetroCard when it falls are forget
about them but another one I don't even
remember a time I wasn't a nail-biter I
only buy my doesn't actually board it
was a movie or from sitting at my desk
and I'm also a cuticle lighter I bite my
nails on board watching TV as you get
older as an adult and you have like real
anxieties to deal with in real life it
only makes things worse I guess I've
tried to stop it's more of like a
subconscious thing I know that these are
gonna be gross but it's kind of like one
of those things where life when someone
tells you what's in a hotdog and right
the expected reaction is like I'm never
gonna eat a hotdog again it's like that
should be the reaction to like what I'm
about to read right then like it
probably won't stop me because I'm a
garbage so apparently nobody can give
you bad bread oh I mean a lot of things
can give you bad breaths is true that's
why you gotta brush your teeth you got
to use that mouthwash yes use mouthwash
two three times a day
whatever whatever next don't carrots
there is a chance that the nails you are
biting off may never grow back I can
live with that are you sure okay I can
twist on that problem and also to like I
think we're almost there already you
know like so fun an overturn uh now
might have been growing back but I'll
keep an eye out for if they don't and
maybe that'll help me stop there are all
kinds of germs crawling under your
fingernails including Staphylococcus
aureus which can lead to a staph
infection oh that's not good then think
about the fact that I'm putting those
hands in my mouth I'm not the best whew
yeah that makes me reconsider this okay
that's gross nice
all right that is gross yeah it's gross
don't see I almost did it again oh my
god not trying to get a staph infection
anytime soon they're more likely to
grind your teeth which can result in
fracturing and loosening or loss of
teeth
maybe because you're just used to biting
things during the day so at night
your subconscious mind is like I'm gonna
ruin my entire body yeah
there's also assumes that we go to the
dentist and you know there's a lot of
assumption area yeah that's a whole
other video no this is pretty scared I
can't lose my team yeah just what I
wanted to bite my nails think you need
your teeth fingertips can turn into a
pus bath but basically the bacteria
cephalic aqus aureus there's that word
again can work its way into small sores
and cause pus buildup and those sores
can open up on the fingertips don't want
a nail biter serving you food yeah we're
putting their fingers anywhere probably
near your orifices the combination of
those words yeah husband bath you're
gonna be looking like you just made it
through the bubonic plague if you are
chewing on your fingernails which I feel
like this is pretty drastic I've never
experienced that myself as a
professional fighter however that sets
me back a little bit I quit apparently
in some instances the old buddy can lead
to oral sti's didn't know I know that
what a lame way to get messy I biting
your nails geez
be like oh like why do you have herpes
like I bite my nails on the toilet
that's gross
yeah that's like yeah that's but since
we're both virgins oh yeah no it's
totally fine oh sorry guys no more love
for you because you might give me sti's
and no one wants that this is it oh yeah
yeah my entire life
hopefully I remember this a couple
months down the road
completely you're done I'm done never
gonna stop my immune system [ __ ] but I'm
never gonna stop I don't think I'm ever
gonna stop either I think I just lost
all the time some of these are really
disgusting yeah so I have to reconsider
it because I'm not trying to have any of
these things happening to me I mean if I
see her biting her nails at her desk I'm
gonna call her yeah I'll call him out -
final verdict still gonna eat a hot dog
so goodbye my dance let's do a follow-up
on in the next couple of weeks and see
if there's any changes the power dies my
mom she tried so hard but my mom tried
so hard